[Musik]
hallo zusammen wir machen heute ein
richtig leckeres nobert bei rezept mit
richtig schön löffelbiskuits außen herum
einer erfrischenden creme und ich würde
sagen ich quatsch gar nicht lange
drumherum ich lege jetzt direkt los mit
der zubereitung und die ganzen
mengenangaben stehen wie um immer hier
unten in der infobox und ich habe zig
kalte schlagsahne hiermit auch heute das
handgerät weil das sind jetzt nur 200
gramm sahne das geht ja immer ganz
schnell mit dem handrührgerät kann
natürlich auch die küchenmaschine
verwenden und da gebe ich jetzt schon
etwas schockiert zucker mit rein bei dem
rezept ist es halt cool wenn der zucker
verwendet und das ganze am vortag
vorbereitet dann habt ihr am nächsten
tag nochmal so eine andere festigkeit
solltet ihr keine zocker haben könnt ihr
das auch eins zu eins gegen normalen
zucker ersetzen und da gebe ich jetzt
auch schon direkt von den extra dazu
[Musik]
ich habe zum schluss noch sattelfester
zugegeben und nur noch mal ganz kurz
berührt und die sahne ist jetzt nicht
ganz so fest also nicht so übertrieben
stark wie man es kennt sondern sie ist
noch recht weit das heißt normalerweise
will ich jetzt noch zehn sekunden weiter
schlagen das ist jetzt aber weil jetzt
kommen noch magerquark und mascarpone
dazu und das wird auch noch mal ganz
kurz untergerührt also wirklich nur zehn
sekunden
und weil es ein erdbeerkuchen sein soll
werde ich gleich noch frische erdbeeren
pürieren und dann könnt ihr euch
entscheiden gibt ihr das püree direkt
mit dazu oder passiert ihr das noch
einmal durch ein feines sieb dann habt
ihr nämlich diese kleinen körnchen das
was wir jetzt schon darüber diskutieren
sah man dann habt ihr den namen nicht
mit drin
[Musik]
ich habe mir jeden fall noch bordeaux
rote lebensmittelfarbe genommen denn ihr
wisst ja das auge isst immer mit und es
war mir so ein bisschen zu hell und
jetzt ist es schön rosa und ich gebe
jetzt schon mal ein bisschen was in
meinen spritzbeutel ich habe keine töne
vorne dran ich habe nämlich gleich was
vor und ich habe die hoffnung dass es
funktioniert ist auch nicht zu viel also
wirklich nur gleich für ein bisschen
deko und den rest geben wir gleich in
dem turnerin doch das sollte ausreichen
und hier habe ich den tortenring auf es
sich die 20 zentimeter ich habe das hier
schon direkt auf eine serviert platte
gestellt und jetzt brauchen wir die
löffelbiskuits und die trunken wir für
gerade einmal maximal zwei sekunden in
milch und dann gehen wir das hier einmal
an den äußeren rand und dann können wir
auch schon auf den boden die
löffelbiskuits geben und dann kommt die
hälfte der creme dazu und da gebe ich
dann auch frische erdbeeren noch mit
rein
[Musik]
so ich habe jetzt bis obenhin
geschichtet und jetzt zeige ich euch ein
trick womit er die torte schön
dekorieren könnt ich habe hier keine
töne dran wie schon erwähnt und sage da
muss ich sehr nah ran kommen damit wird
das zeigen können jetzt schneiden wir
quasi schräg einmal rein ich zeige euch
das mal
so nett war
also einfach nur schräg anschneiden
abonniert können wir ein schönes muster
außen herum zaubern
ja
okay ich mache glaube ich noch einmal
ein bisschen größer dann ist das muster
auch schöner ein verstreichen das geld
einfach das merkt man ja nicht und dann
müsste es aber wirklich ein schönes
muster ergeben
[Musik]
also ich finde es jetzt schon richtig
süß aber on top kommen noch frische
erdbeeren gerne auch in berlin gehabt
und am allerbesten schmeckt es wirklich
wenn ihr das jetzt mindestens vier
stunden dann kühlt in meinem fall mache
ich das einfach über nacht auch kuhlmann
dann könnte das halt am vortag
vorbereiten dann ist alles so ein
bisschen entspannter und wenn ihr die
bären jetzt schon drauf tun würde dann
würden sie halt das morgen einfach nicht
mehr so schön aussehen und ein bisschen
weicher werden daher mache ich die
morgen erst drauf also bis morgen chips
so ist ist der nächste tag und alles
konnte richtig gut durch die
löffelbiskuits haben sie so ein bisschen
nach innen geneigt lieber so einer
pflanze aber eigentlich macht es
umgekehrt aber ich fand es ganz böse
ich werde jetzt den tortenring entfernen
ok bisschen was weggerissen was aber
überhaupt nicht schlimm ist es aber auch
gleich das ist wirklich nicht mal da
kommt gleich noch puderzucker und jetzt
kommt aber erst mal in die mitte noch
etwas frisches ich merke auch schon in
dem ich die frucht hier so reinlegen die
creme ist richtig schön angenehm fest
geworden und jetzt einfach wahllos
irgendwie verteilen das muss auch gar
kein schinken sein und dann werde ich
außen rum nur noch ein bisschen
puderzucker dran machen und das war es
eigentlich schon ihr könnt es direkt
servieren und das hält insgesamt drei
tage lang also dann sollte es wirklich
verzerrt werden ich verabschiede mich an
der stelle ich wünsche euch ganz viel
spaß beim nachmachen hinterlasst dem
video auf jeden fall ein bäumchen nach
oben wenn es euch gefallen hat und dann
sehen wir uns auch bei meinem nächsten
rezeptes gibt's da nicht wir sind noch
mitten im ramadan aber ich weiß dass der
extrem lecker schmeckt und ich mach dir
einfach auf instagram also bis dahin
tschüss
[Musik]